things can change very quickly as we close
in on the first votes being cast in the 2020
democratic primary, just look at the last
24 hours, which have been very good.
Very good for Senator Bernie Sanders.
Yesterday.
I told you 24 hours ago I told you the Joe
Biden had picked up some support both nationally
and an Iowa and recent polls.
The good news came in a big wave over the
last 24 hours for Bernie Sanders and let's
go through it.
We have a new national poll, a new California
poll, and a new hypothetical matchups poll
against Donald Trump to look at.
Let's go through them one at a time starting
with a national poll.
The big story, a new CNN poll has Bernie leading
nationally.
The poll says Bernie 27 Joe Biden 24 there's
a three and a half point margin of error,
so technically it could be tied, but again
a shift in momentum in the direction of Bernie
Sanders.
In this same poll, Elizabeth Warren is polling
just 14 if we are to believe recent polls,
we really have a two candidate race right
now.
This is really Biden and Bernie.
One of them will be the nominee.
If we can believe recent polls, if recent
polls can be trusted, Elizabeth Warren is
all but out of this thing, not polling in
second place anywhere unless you go all the
way back to an IBD poll that is like 15 or
20 polls old at this point in time.
We'll get to more of that in a second.
Next, new polling out of California.
We're in a university of Southern California,
Rossier school of education poll.
That's a mouthful.
Bernie is leading Bernie 28 Biden 24.
Now, what's important to understand about
California, California is a huge state population-wise,
many delegates to be had from California,
but very unlikely that California will be
a difference maker in the primary.
I'll explain why California, uh, apportions
delegates in proportion to, uh, the percentage
of the vote that different candidates get.
So if Bernie beats Biden 28 to 24, they get
a very similar number of delegates out of
California, 28 and 24% respectively.
If the numbers are flipped, it's still a very
similar number of delegates for the two of
them.
So California is important.
Momentum wise, it's a huge state.
And for PR purposes it's important.
But understand that you know, in 2016, Bernie
lost the California primary to Hillary Clinton,
but he had like 46% of the vote and got roughly
46% of the delegates this time because it's
a bigger field.
Bernie may win, but actually end up with fewer
delegates than he did in 2016.
But that's for the future.
Uh, once the first four primaries are out
of the way, we'll look at California in more
detail.
And then third, and maybe most interestingly,
we have another one of these hypothetical
matchup polls where people are said, if the
nominee were Bernie, how would you vote on
Trump versus Bernie?
If the nominee were Biden, how would you work
on Trump?
How would you vote on Trump versus Biden?
And the results are compelling.
This is from survey USA consisting of more
than 4,000 registered voters.
The numbers are fascinating.
The person with the biggest lead over Trump
is Bernard Sanders.
52 to 43.
Trump minus nine against Bernie Biden is defeating
Trump by seven in the hypothetical matchup.
Bloomberg leading Trump by six Warren leading
Trump by three booed edge edge leading Trump
by three.
Uh, but with more undecideds Andrew Yang leading
Trump by two.
Even Tom Stier is even with Trump, the two
candidates that lose to Trump and the hypothetical
mashups.
Amy Klobuchar and tool C Gabbert losing by
the most Trump ahead of tool C by five which
will anger a small but loud portion of my
audience.
So what's the takeaway knowing that the establishment
is going to run a full court press for Joe
Biden throughout the primary.
What this tells us is we've got a real race
here and the race is Biden versus Bernie.
When it comes to facing Trump, Bernie is regularly
doing the best against Trump compared to other
candidates that shouldn't be ignored.
When we think about electability, unless someone
can explain to me how Warren is still in this
thing.
I don't see her having a path to the nomination.
So my question to you is, can we now say that
this is almost completely a two candidate
race, Biden versus Bernie?
Or do you still see Warren or anybody else
having a path to the nomination?
I also can't restate the importance enough,
uh, that, um, the, we want to have a primary
that doesn't hurt our chances of removing
Donald Trump.
So yesterday I talked about Hillary Clinton's
comment that nobody likes Bernie and her hesitation
to say she would support Bernie if he is the
nominee.
That's the self-destructive garbage.
That is the last thing we need.
The absolutely last thing we need right now.
Let's get out there.
Let's support the people we like based on
their policies.
Let's vote.
Let's then rally around the removal of Donald
Trump, a very solid couple of days for Bernie
Sanders.
Reminder, my question to you is, Warren's
fill in this thing, she seems to be out to
me, but I want to hear from you.
We will continue our coverage of this on our
Instagram page.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
While you're there.
Follow me
at
David dot captains